So lately, my son's behavior has been triggering my husband big time.
Not this one. The big one.
And both of our kids act out in very different ways.
My daughter tends to go to anger and rage and tantrums,
and my son tends to crumble and cry.
And when that happens,
my husband loses his mind.
Extremely triggered.
So today I started talking to him about why that might be,
and it turns out he used to act the same way as a kid,
but he wasn't allowed to feel or express those emotions,
and his mom worked all the time,
so he was left to deal with those feelings all by himself.
So it's just a good reminder to remember
if your kid is acting in a way that is especially triggering for you,
you've got to look at yourself
and start to deconstruct why
that might bother you more than other things.
Because it usually will come back to an issue
that you have not resolved from your childhood.